SITUATION IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
NO TOPIC WAS OFF LIMITS SO
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO, HERE IS
PART 1 OF MY INTERVIEW WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU SO MUCH
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU SO MUC
MUCH.
I BET YOU HAVE DONE A LOT OVER
THE YEARS.
I AM GOING TO DO SOMETHING TO MY
WILL READ THE TRANSCRIPT BECAUSE
EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT
WHISTLE-BLOWERS, NOT
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
IT SAYS, I WOULD LIKE YOU TO DO
IT'S A PAPER.
YOU ARE FIRST TALKING ABOUT
CONGRATULATIONS COME OUT LIKE
YOU ARE DOING US A FAVOR.
BECAUSE OUR COUNTRY HAS BEEN
THROUGH A LOT.
UKRAINE KNOWS A LOT ABOUT IT.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THIS WHOLE
SITUATION WITH UKRAINE.
AND I GUESS YOU HAVE ONE OF YOUR
WEALTHY PEOPLE, THEY SAY UKRAINE
HAS IT COME A LOT OF THINGS WENT
ON, THE WHOLE SITUATION.
YOU SAY, I THINK YOU ARE
SURROUNDING YOURSELF WITH SOME
OF THE SAME PEOPLE.
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL CALL YOU OR
YOUR PEOPLE, AND I WOULD LIKE TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
>> President Trump: BY THE
WAY, JUST SO YOU UNDERSTAND, WE
ARE LOOKING AT THE 2016
ELECTION, WHICH WAS A DISASTER.
WE WENT THROUGH HELL, MY
ADMINISTRATION.
PEOPLE DESTROYED, THEIR LIVES
DESTROYED, NOT ONE PERSON
COLLUDED.
THEY FOUND NO COLLUSION, NO
NOTHING, AND THEY WENT THROUGH
HELL.
THERE WAS THE DNC SERVER THAT
HAD NEVER WENT TO THE FBI.
THE FBI DIDN'T TAKE IT.
IT WAS TAKEN BY SOMEBODY I GUESS
I'LL STRIKE, THAT'S WHAT I HAVE
HEARD.
THAT IS NOT AN ELECTION GOING
INTO THE FUTURE.
THAT IS FOR A PAST ELECTION THAT
WAS A CATASTROPHE.
AND IT WAS A VERY UNFAIR
SITUATION.
AFTER TWO AND A HALF YEARS OF
TWO YEARS, THEY FOUND NO
COLLUSION, NO NOTHING.
>> Sean: FOUR INVESTIGATIONS.
THE HOUSE INTEL BIPARTISAN.
>> President Trump: THAT IS
RIGHT, MANY, MANY
INVESTIGATIONS.
THAT IS ALL THEY HAVE DONE IS
INVESTIGATIONS AND YET ONE OF
THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
INVESTIGATIONS IN THE LAST TWO
AND HALF YEARS.
THE FIRST TWO AND A HALF YEARS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS
GOING ON, AND THEN YOU SEE ALL
OF THIS HORRIBLE STUFF, AND THEN
YOU HEAR ABOUT UKRAINE.
YOU HAVE BEEN HEARING ABOUT IT.
I HEARD CLINTON WAS INVOLVED.
I HEARD THEY GOT SOMEBODY WHO
WROTE THE FAKE DOSSIER.
WAS IT OUT IT OUT OF UKRAINE?
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED.
AND I ASSUME THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, I WOULD LIKE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO FIND OUT
WHAT IS GOING ON.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT, WE ARE
INVESTIGATING CORRUPTION.
AND I ACTUALLY HEARD
GREGG JARRETT IN NUMEROUS PEOPLE
SAY COME I HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
DO.
THAT IS NOT A QUESTION, CAN I DO
IT OR DON'T I DO IT?
WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
INVESTIGATE COOPERATE --
CORRUPTION.
IN MY OPINION, THAT IS WHAT IT
WAS CORRUPTION AND IF UKRAINE
WOULD KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT THE
2016 ELECTION, YOU HAVE TO GIVE
THAT INFORMATION.
I HOPE THEY WOULD GIVE THE
INFORMATION AND EVERYBODY AGREES
WITH ME 100%.
BUT WHEN I LOOK AT EXPERTS ON
YOUR SHOW AND OTHER EXPERTS,
THEY ARE ALL SIN YOU HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO DO THAT.
SO I THINK I HAVE A FRIEND A --
READ A CONVERSATION TAKEN DOWN A
READ A CONVERSATION TAKEN DOWN D
TRANSCRIBED A PERFECT
CONVERSATION.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW PEOPLE --
>> President Trump: HE
ACTUALLY SAID THIS.
DID YOU KNOW THIS WAS GOING TO
BE A DOCUMENT ANALYZED?
I SAID, NO, BUT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND, YOU ASSUME ARE MANY
PEOPLE THAT IT'S EITHER BEING
TAPED OR THEY HAVE STENOGRAPHERS
OR TAPES AND I THINK THEY DON'T
LIKE TO TAPE WORLD LEADERS.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THAT.
SO THEY HAVE STENOGRAPHERS AND
PEOPLE TO TAKE THE TRANSCRIBERS,
A PERFECT TRANSCRIPTION OF A
PERFECT CONVERSATION.
THE OTHER THING IS, WHEN I'M
TALKING TO SOMEBODY WORLD
LEADERS, ALMOST ANYBODY, I
ASSUME THAT STATE DEPARTMENTS
COME I THINK MOM DOMINIC
MIKE POMPEO, MANY, MANY PEOPLE.
DO YOU THINK I WILL SAY
SOMETHING WRONG 25 OR 30 OR TWO
OR TEN OR SOMETHING, BUT A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
SO I THINK SOME LISTEN FOR
EDUCATIONAL REASONS AND SOME
BECAUSE MEMBERS OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT BUT THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE LISTENING TO US.
AND TO THINK THEY TOOK THAT CALL
NOW, THE BIG THING I DID WITH
THAT CALL, SEAN, THE BIGGEST
THING, RELEASED IT.
BECAUSE THE WHISTLE-BLOWERS SAID
HORRIBLE THINGS ABOUT THIS CALL.
I THINK THEY SAID THERE WERE
EIGHT, SEVEN OR EIGHT QUID PRO
QUO'S.
IT WAS REALLY A TERRIBLE CALL,
ALL THESE TERRIBLE THINGS ABOUT
THIS CALL.
I SAID, THAT WASN'T A BAD A CALL
AT ALL.
WHAT ELSE HAPPENED?
THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE SO THAT
WAS PERFECTLY FINE CALL, THERE
WAS NO PRESSURE, THERE WAS NO
ANYTHING.
ONE OF HIS TOP PEOPLE, I GUESS,
ONE OF HIS HEADS OF STATES CAME
OUT AND SAID THIS WAS A PERFECT
CALL.
THERE WAS NO PRESSURE.
THEY DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT.
TO THINK THAT THEY ARE USING
THAT.
NOW THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT THAT
ANYMORE.
BECAUSE THAT LEVEL WAS SO GOOD.
THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT ANYMORE,
SEAN.
THE REASON THEY DON'T TALK ABOUT
IT, THERE IS NOTHING TO TALK
ABOUT.
SPENT THE REASON, THE NEXT THING
YOU SAY THOUGH, I THINK, MAKES
YOUR POINT.
YOU SAY AS YOU SAW YESTERDAY,
THE WHOLE NONSENSE ENDED WITH A
POOR PERFORMANCE BY A MAN NAMED
ROBERT MUELLER, INCOMPETENT
PERFORMANCE BUT THEY SAY A LOT
OF IT STARTED WITH UKRAINE.
WHATEVER YOU DO, IT IS
IMPORTANT.
>> President Trump: AND IT
DID, IT ENDED WITH A POOR
PERFORMANCE AND THIS IS AFTER
TWO YEARS OF AN INVESTIGATION
WHETHER $45 MILLION OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT, THEY HAD 2,500
SUBPOENAS, 500 WITNESSES, ALL
BECAUSE PROBABLY HILLARY CLINTON
SAID JUST LIKE SHE DID WITH
TULSI GABBARD, JUST LIKE SHE DID
WITH JILL STEIN, SHE SAID "JILL
STEIN IS A RUSSIAN ASSET.
NOW COME I DON'T KNOW JILL
STEIN.
I KNOW A ENVIRONMENTALIST AND
PROBABLY A GOOD WOMAN BUT THE
LESSON SHE HAS A RUSSIAN ASSET.
I DON'T KNOW TULSI GABBARD BUT I
KNOW WHEN THINK SHE IS NOT AN
ASSET OF RUSSIA.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SICK.
THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THEM.
>> Sean: I WANT TO SHOW YOU
THIS AND WE WILL PUT IT UP ON
THE SCREEN FOR PEOPLE AT HOME.
UKRAINIAN EFFORTS TO SABOTAGE
TRUMP BACKFIRE.
THIS WAS JANUARY 11, 2017.
YOU WERE INAUGURATED.
THIS ARTICLE TALKS ABOUT HOW
UKRAINE WORKED WITH HILLARY TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTIONS.
THEY GIVE CHAPTER AND VERSE HOW
THEY DID IT.
NOW, AS THE PRESIDENT, DO YOU
FEEL THERE WAS -- YOU SPENT TWO
AND HALF YEARS WITH RUSSIAN
COLLUSION AND IGNORE THE DOSSIER
IN UKRAINE ADMITTING THAT THEY
HELPED HILLARY.
>> President Trump: THE
DOSSIER WAS A DISGRACE.
THE DOSSIER WAS TOTALLY FAKE.
NOW IT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
FAKE.
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW HOW THAT WAS
DONE.
YOU HAVE A TRACK RECORD NOW AND
YOU KNOW AS WELL AS EVERYBODY
THEY ARE DOING AN INVESTIGATION,
BUT I THINK BEFORE YOU DO THE
INVESTIGATION, SO THEY DO A FAKE
DOSSIER ON ME.
THEY TRIED TO RELEASE IT BEFORE
THE ELECTION TO AFFECT THE
ELECTION.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY DID.
IT'S THE ONLY THING I RESPECT
ABOUT THE PROCESS IS THEY
REFUSED TO PUT IT IN BEFORE THE
ELECTION BECAUSE IT COULD HAVE
HAD A LITTLE IMPACT.
MAYBE IT COULD HAVE HAD A LITTLE
MORE THAN THE IMPACT.
THEY DO A FAKE DOSSIER THAT WAS
PROBABLY MEANT TO GET OUT BEFORE
THE ELECTION SO THAT THEY COULD
AFFECT THE ELECTIONS.
AND LOOK AT THE PEOPLE THAT
WROTE IT.
LOOK AT WHERE THEY CAME FROM.
AND LOOK AT THE WIFE OF THE MAN
WHO WORKS, I WON'T EVEN MENTION
NAMES, AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
AND SHE'S ON THE PAYROLL OF THE
COMPANY THAT ROBERT MUELLER
NEVER HEARD OF DURING HIS
TESTIMONY.
THINK OF IT, NEVER HEARD OF IT,
THE COMPANY.
DO YOU KNOW COLLUSION GPS?
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON
HERE.
AFTER SPENDING 45 --
>> Sean: YOU DIDN'T KNOW
HILLARY CLINTON'S ATTORNEY AT
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION WAS ON
HIS TEAM?
>> President Trump: LOOK, THE
WHOLE THING WAS A DISGRACE.
THEY DESTROYED A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THEY RUINED THEIR LIVES.
AND WHAT WAS GOING ON WAS
ABSOLUTELY CORRUPT.
LET'S SEE WHAT ELSE HAPPENS.
>> Sean: THEY SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN TO THE COUNTRY.
>> President Trump: LET ME
TELL YOU, SEAN FOR SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN TO OUR COUNTRY AGAIN AND
THAT SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO A
PRESIDENT AGAIN.
LISTEN, "THE WASHINGTON POST"
WHICH IS A FAKE DEAL,
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAS A
STORY ON INAUGURATION DAY IF YOU
ARE IS AFTER THE INAUGURATION
DAY.
ESSENTIALLY SAYING NOW THE
IMPEACHMENT BEGINS.
SO THIS WAS THE WHOLE THING.
BUT ONE OF THE WORST THINGS,
EVEN BEFORE MUELLER WAS
PETER STRZOK AND LISA PAGE, THE
TWO LEPERS WHERE HE SAID OR SHE
SAID COME I GUESS THAT GOING TO
WIN 100 MILLION TO ONE, SHE'S
GOING TO WIN BUT IF SHE DOESN'T
WE GO TO THE INSURANCE POLICY.
WHEN HE SAID AN INSURANCE
POLICY, THAT MEANS RIGHT NOW IS
THE INSURANCE POLICY, OKAY?
I THOUGHT IT WAS OVER AFTER THE
FIRST RIDICULOUS THING WITH
MUELLER, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, IT
IS A DISGRACE.
WHEN "THE WASHINGTON POST" COMES
OUT AND SAYS, NOW IT BEGINS THE
IMPEACHMENT AND YOU SEE EVERY
ARTICLE, NO MATTER WHAT YOU DO,
NO MATTER HOW GOOD YOU ARE DOING
IT, NOBODY IS WITH THE BEST
ECONOMY, THE BEST EMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS, WE HAVE THE BEST OF
EVERYTHING.
WE REBUILT THE MILITARY.
WITH ALL OF THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE DONE, REGULATION CUTS, THE
BIGGEST TAX CUT IN HISTORY, SO
MANY THINGS, OUR ENERGY, ENERGY
INDEPENDENT NOW, THAT IS WHY YOU
DON'T SEE OUR BOOKS BLOWN UP.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS.
BUT THEY WON'T GIVE YOU A DECENT
ARTICLE NO MATTER WHAT YOU DO
COME IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IT'S A FIX.
THESE ARE DISHONEST PEOPLE.
WHEN THEY SAY THE IMPEACHMENT
ALBICANS, SEAN, THIS WAS THE DAY
OF THE INAUGURATION.
>> Sean: HAVE YOU SEEN A
MONTAGE FOR TELEVISION ON THE
SHOW, TWO DAYS AFTER YOU WERE
ELECTED.
AND ALL THROUGHOUT 2017, ALL
THROUGHOUT 2018 AND HERE WE ARE
HERE.
MEANWHILE, THIS COLLUSION WITH
THE GOVERNMENT, THE POLITICAL
ARTICLE SAID UKRAINIAN AMERICAN
OPERATIVE WHO WAS CONSULTING FOR
THE DNC MET WITH TOP OFFICIALS
IN THE UKRAINIAN EMBASSY IN
WASHINGTON IN AN EFFORT TO
EXPOSE TIES BETWEEN TRUMP AND
TOP CAMPAIGN AIDE PAUL MANAFORT
AND RUSSIA.
THIS WAS BEFORE, THAT HAPPEN
INTERFERENCE.
>> President Trump: SURE IT
HAPPEN.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FBI, THEY
WERE DOING WORK ON ME FROM
BEFORE THE ELECTION EVER TOOK
PLACE.
VERY EARLY ON.
SEAN, LONG BEFORE THE
NOVEMBER 8TH ELECTION, THEY WERE
DOING WORK ON ME.
AND NOW, WITH OTHER SENATORS OR
OTHER PEOPLE IN HIGH OFFICE,
THEY WOULD SAY, BY THE WAY COME
I THINK YOU HAVE A CHINESE SPY
WORKING FOR YOU.
YOU KNOW WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
DIANNE FEINSTEIN HAD A CHAUFFEUR
FOR MANY, MANY YEARS WORKED FOR
HER AND THEY WENT UP TO HER AND
SAID, LISTEN HE MAY BE A CHINESE
SPY.
SHE FIRED HIM.
NOBODY TOLD ME ANYTHING ABOUT
THAT.
NOBODY EVER TOLD ME.
WHAT THEY DID IS A DISGRACE.
AND I WILL ADMIT, THAT SHOULD
NEVER HAPPEN TO ANOTHER
PRESIDENT.
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENED TO PEOPLE
WHO WORKED FOR ME, GOOD PEOPLE,
WHAT THEY HAD TO DO, THEY WENT
BUST TRYING TO PAY FOR THEIR
LEGAL FEES.
THEY CAME TO THE WASHINGTON TO
DO A FANTASTIC JOB.
THEY WERE BRIGHT EYED
BUSHYTAILED.
THEY CAME TO WASHINGTON WANTED
TO DO A GOOD JOB ON HEALTH CARE,
AND ALL SORTS OF THINGS.
AND THEY LEFT AND THEY WERE DARK
PEOPLE.
THEY LEFT DARK.
AND THIS WAS ALL A PHONY SCAM.
AND THEN YOU HAVE
HILLARY CLINTON SAYING, TWO DAYS
AGO, TULSI GABBARD IS A RUSSIAN
ASSET.
AND THAT JILL STEIN IS A RUSSIAN
AGENT.
AND I SAID, WAIT A MINUTE TO
COMMIT TOOK ME TWO AND A HALF
YEARS.
I WISH YOU WOULD HAVE SAID THAT
EARLIER BECAUSE PEOPLE WOULD
HAVE REALIZE SHE'S CRAZY, SHE'S
CRAZY.
BUT TWO AND A HALF YEARS, SEAN,
WE WENT THROUGH THIS AND IT
STARTED BEFORE THE ELECTION.
AND PRESIDENT OBAMA IN SEPTEMBER
WAS TOLD ABOUT RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE.
AND HE DIDN'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO DO A THING
ABOUT IT BECAUSE HE ASSUMED
HILLARY WAS GOING TO WIN.
HE DIDN'T DO A THING ABOUT THAT.
NOBODY BRINGS THAT UP.
NOBODY BRINGS UP THAT STATEMENT
TO THE PRESIDENT OF RUSSIA AT
THE TIME.
NOBODY BRINGS IT UP ABOUT THE
DOSSIER AND THE ELECTION.
IT IS A VERY DOUBLE STANDARD.
IT IS A SAD THING.
NOW, YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
FROM CLINTON AND FROM OBAMA AND
YOU ALSO HAVE NEVER TRUMP
ERRORS, BUSH COME I CAN
UNDERSTAND THE BUSH IS NOT
EXACTLY LOVING ME.
BECAUSE WE TOOK ON THE CLINTON
FAMILY, AND WE BEAT THEM BOTH.
AND I GUESS YOU WOULD CALL THEM
DYNASTIES, RIGHT, THAT'S CALLED
A DYNASTY.
BUT WE BEAT THEM BOTH.
AND I GUESS THEY DON'T EXACTLY
LIKE ME, BUT WE ARE DOING A
GREAT JOB.
WITH ALL OF THE GREAT THINGS
GOING ON AND OUT TO THINK IT
STARTS UP AGAIN.
IT WAS REPUTED TO HER THREE
TIMES.
AND IT STARTS AGAIN.
THIS TIME, OVER ABSOLUTELY
PERFECT PHONE CALL WITH A VERY
NICE GENTLEMAN.
WHEN I READ IT COME I SAID THIS
IS LIKE A PERFECT CONVERSATION.
I KNEW IT BEFORE HAND, BUT I
WOULD HAVE POSSIBLY SAID
SOMETHING, NO.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IS I IMMEDIATELY
RELEASE THE CONVERSATION.
OKAY?
SO NOW WE HAVE A CONVERSATION
THAT IS PERFECT.
AND IS IS TRANSCRIBE AND IT'S
DONE BY TOTAL PROFESSIONAL
PEOPLE, STENOGRAPHERS OR
WHATEVER YOU WOULD CALL THEM.
SO WE HAVE AN EXACT
CONVERSATION.
I RELEASE IT.
NOW, YOU DON'T HEAR FROM THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER ANYMORE BECAUSE
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER WAS TALKING
ABOUT THIS CONVERSATION IN PHONY
TERMS JUST LIKE ADAM SCHIFF MADE
UP MY CONVERSATION.
HE SAID SEVEN OR EIGHT TIMES,
THINK OF THIS, ADAM SCHIFF,
SHIFTY ADAM SCHIFF, SEVEN OR
EIGHT TIMES, IT WAS TERRIBLE,
SEAN, SEVEN OR EIGHT TIMES THATI
PAID FOR QUID PRO QUO.
AND I SAID, NOT ONLY SEVEN OR
EIGHT TIMES BUT NO TIMES BECAUSE
IT WASN'T DONE.
HE SAID, DON'T MAKE HE IS A
CORRUPT POLITICIAN.
THINK ABOUT WHAT HE IS DOING
BASED ON A VERY MINOR
CONVERSATION WITH THE PRESIDENT
OF THE COUNTRY WHO JUST GOT
ELECTED.
A CONGRATULATIONS, THE FIRST
PAGES CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
WIN ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
IT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN NICER.
I TELL YOU, LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID
WHEN HE READ IT, HE SAID "I
NEVER KNEW THAT TRUMP WAS AT
NICE OF A PERSON.
THIS IS SUCH A NICE CONVERSATION
THIS IS SUCH A NICE CONVERSATIO
CONVERSATION."
NO, HE SAID "I NEVER KNEW HE WAS
SO NICE."
I VIEWED THAT AS A COMPLEMENT IN
THIS CASE BUT ANYWAY, LOOK IT IS
A DISGRACE WHAT'S GOING ON.
IN THE MEANTIME WE ARE DOING A
GOOD JOB RUNNING THE COUNTRY.
THAT IS WHAT I'M FOCUSED ON AND
THIS IS AN UNFAIR SITUATION.
>> Sean: LOOK AT THE DOUBLE
STANDARD HILLARY AND THE
DOSSIER, UKRAINE INTERFERING ON
HER BEHALF AND ADAM SCHIFF FOR
THREE YEARS TELLING US LIES AND
THEN HE'S CONNECTED TO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER SO WE CAN'T BRING
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER IN.
>> President Trump: THEY MET
WITH THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
NOBODY KNEW THAT.
WE JUST FOUND OUT THAT THEY
KNEW.
WHERE IS THE PERSON THAT GAVE
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER THE
INFORMATION?
IS THAT PERSON A SPY?
OR DOES THAT PERSON EVEN EXIST?
I HAVE A FEELING THAT PERSON
DOESN'T EXIST.
I THINK SCHIFF MADE IT UP HERE
IT'S APPARENTLY SCHIFF AND
JOE BIDEN KNOW HIM.
>> President Trump: THEY SAY
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER, THEY DON'T
NEED WHISTLE-BLOWER ANYMORE.
WHY DON'T THEY NEED THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER ANYMORE?
BECAUSE IT IS AN ACCOUNT OF MY
CONVERSATION THAT WAS TOTALLY
FUNKED.
NOW, THEY HAD NO IDEA I WOULD
RELEASE THE CONVERSATION.
AND I'M TALKING TO A FOREIGN
LEADER.
I DON'T WANT TO RELEASE IT
CONVERSATION.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO TALK TO ME
OR ANY OTHER PRESIDENT.
BUT THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED, AND IT
IS A DISGRACE.
>> Sean: I WANT TO GO TO THE
DOUBLE STANDARD AGAIN, WHETHER
THE DOSSIER OR UKRAINE HELPING
AND INTERFERING IN THE
ELECTIONS, THERE IS NO QUID PRO
QUO.
THEN YOU CAN ADD HUNTER BIDEN
AND JOE BIDEN ON TAPE BRAGGING
ABOUT USING TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
DEMAND THE FIRING OF THE
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR.
HUNTER BIDEN MISSED NO
EXPERIENCE UKRAINE CHINA, NO
EXPERIENCE PRIVATE EQUITY.
>> President Trump: THROWN OUT
OF THE NAVY, OKAY.
HUNTER WAS THROWN OUT OF THE
NAVY.
>> Sean: WHY WAS HE GIVEN THAT
MONEY?
IS IT A PAY OFF?
>> President Trump: IN MY
OPINION, IT IS A PAYOFF.
WHY ELSE WOULD IT BE?
HUNTER BIDEN WITH NO EXPERIENCE.
I HEAR THE NUMBERS ARE
168 MILLION A MONTH.
THEY GOT A $3 MILLION PAYMENT IN
ALL OF THOSE.
OKAY?
AND THAT IS CORRUPTION.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HAS TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
LOOK AT MY WATCH THIS CRAZY
ANDERSON COOPER THE OTHER DAY
DURING THE DEBATE.
I APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING TO ASK
THE QUESTION.
AND IF THAT WERE ME --
>> Sean: HE DECLARED HIS
INNOCENCE.
>> President Trump: IF THAT
WERE MY SON THAT TOOK THIS
$168 MILLION FROM A QUESTIONABLE
ENERGY COMPANY AND THEY KNEW
NOTHING ABOUT ENERGY.
HE KNEW NOTHING ABOUT ENERGY AND
HAS A BAD TRACK RECORD INCLUDING
GETTING THROWN OUT OF THE NAVY,
EVEN THE WAY HE GOT INTO THE
NAVY IS INTERESTING IN HIS
POSITION.
IF THAT WERE A DON JR. OR
ERIC TRUMP WHO ARE VERY
OUTSTANDING YOUNG MEN, IT WOULD
BE THE BIGGEST STORY OF THIS
ENTRY.
>> Sean: WHAT DOES IT SAY
ABOUT THE MEDIA?
I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> President Trump: THE MEDIA
IS CORRUPT.
NOT ALL THE MEDIA.
I KNOW SOME GREAT PEOPLE,
INCLUDING YOU, BUT I KNOW SOME
GREAT GENERALIST.
LOOK, THEY GIVE BLITZER PRINT
SURPRISES TO PEOPLE THAT GOT IT
WRONG.
IN ALL THESE PEOPLE FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WHICH IS
THE FAKE NEWSPAPER, WHAT YOU
DON'T EVEN WANT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE ANYMORE, AND THEY
ARE FAKE.
BUT YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," AND YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THE REPORTING
THEY DO AND IT TURNED OUT TO BE
ALL WRONG AND AFTER THE
ELECTION, "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
APOLOGIZED FOR THEIR COVERAGE
BECAUSE THEY WERE COVERING AND
SO WHEN I WON, THEY ACTUALLY
APOLOGIZE TO THEIR SUBSCRIBERS
BECAUSE THEY WERE LOSING
THOUSANDS OF THOUSANDS OF
SUBSCRIBERS.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WROTE AN
APOLOGY.
YOU KNOW, WILL COMMIT WASN'T
REALLY AN APOLOGY.
IT WAS.
THE COVERED ME SO BADLY.
AND I THINK I SAID, YOU KNOW,
THE GOOD NEWS, WE WILL BE
COVERED AGAIN.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO COME I
GOT COVERED WORSE.
I GOT COVERED WORSE.
BUT THAT'S OKAY.
GOT COVERED WORSE.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN.
I'VE HEARD THAT ONE PERSON THAT
USED TO BE FIVE OR SIX BUT NOW
DOWN TO ONE, HONEST ABE LINCOLN.
HE GOT THE WORST PRESS OF
ANYBODY.
I DISPUTED.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU, THE
DEMOCRATS ALREADY JUMPED OUT OF
THE PLANE.
CAN'T GO BACK.
DO YOU SEE A SCENARIO WHERE THEY
WILL IMPEACH YOU.
THERE WILL BE A TRIAL AND THEN
THE PEOPLE GET TO SPEAK.
WOULD THAT BE THE ULTIMATE
REVENGE, WHICH IS YOUR
REELECTION AT THE PEOPLE SPEAK?
>> President Trump: EVERYBODY
TELL ME IT WILL BE GREAT FOR US
AS A REPUBLICAN PARTY IF THEY
ACTUALLY IMPEACH ME BECAUSE THE
40 SEATS AND THERE ARE MANY MORE
THAN THE 42, 40, 45 SEEDS WHERE
I WON OR DID REALLY WELL OR VERY
I WON OR DID REALLY WELL OR VERC
I WON OR DID REALLY WELL OR VERO
I WON OR DID REALLY WELL OR VERE
I WON OR DID REALLY WELL OR VER.
THOSE PEOPLE WILL GET HAMMERED.
MEANING RUNNING IN CONGRESS.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THAT IS TRUE
OR NOT.
I DO SAY THIS AND I CAN SEE IT
BECAUSE, I MEAN, LOOK AT THE
FUND-RAISING.
MONEY HAS NEVER COME IN LIKE
THIS.
LOOK AT MY PHONE NUMBERS HAVE
BEEN THE HIGHEST.
I WAS IN DALLAS THE OTHER NIGHT.
WE SET A RECORD IN THE STADIUM.
I DON'T KNOW, IT'S GOT TO BE AN
ARENA THAT IS 20 YEARS OLD.
WE HAVE A RECORD.
WE HAVE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
OUTSIDE WATCHING ON BIG SCREENS.
THEY'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THAT, BUT IT'S EVERYPLACE.
DALLAS, WHICH WE LOVE, THAT WAS
GREAT.
THEY DID A GREAT JOB, GREAT
PLACE BUT IT'S THAT WAY EVERY
PLACE.
LOOK AT LOUISIANA, LOUISIANA THE
OTHER NIGHT, THE GOVERNOR AT
ROUTE 66, WE COULDN'T GET 50%
BUT NOW A REALLY GREAT
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE.
LOOK AT NORTH CAROLINA, A GREAT
STATE, GREAT PEOPLE.
TWO RACES THAT WILL BE LOST.
I WENT IN AND MADE A SPEECH, LET
EVERYBODY KNOW I RESPECT THESE
TWO GUYS AND THEY WILL BE GREAT.
THEY BOTH WON.
"HANNITY" REPORTING TONIGHT FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE NOW CONTINUE WITH MY
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
LET ME ASK YOU, 2020 IS HERE
COME ALL RIGHT?
YOU SAID PUBLICLY YOU DON'T
THINK JOE MAKES IT.
AND ELIZABETH WARREN, HERS TO
LOSE.
YOU HAVE BERNIE, MAYOR PETE,
WHATEVER.
THEN YOU LOOK AT THEIR
POSITIONS, TOP MARGINAL TAX
RATES 70%.
>> President Trump: MUCH
HIGHER.
>> Sean: 90% CORPORATE TAX
RATE, THE NEW CRANE DEAL HAD A
$6 TRILLION, MEDICARE FOR ALL,
NO PRIVATE OPTIONS.
IN RUNNING AGAINST ONE OF THOSE?
DO YOU THINK OF THIS?
>> President Trump: I DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
LAST TIME I TOOK ON
ELIZABETH WARREN I THOUGHT SHE
WAS GONE.
BERNIE, POCAHONTAS.
THERE IS ONLY ONE.
IT IS NOT HER.
SO WHAT HAPPENS.
AND SHE ROSE FROM THE ASHES AND
I GIVE HER CREDIT FOR THAT.
BUT I DON'T LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
IT.
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED THE
GREEN NEW DEAL, FINE.
ALL OF IT IS FINE.
PAYING 96% IN TEXAS IS ALL FINE.
I WANT THEM TO KEEP TALKING
ABOUT IT.
AND WHEN IT'S TIME TO RUN, I
WILL RUN.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO TALK THEM
OUT OF IT, SEAN.
IT IS TOO EARLY TO TALK ABOUT.
AND NOT ONLY THAT, CAN YOU
BELIEVE IT?
RIGHT IN THE CORNER OF THAT
BEAUTIFUL BUILDING.
I WAS IN THE FIRST NIGHT WITH
THE FIRST LADY.
I'M STANDING IN AN AREA WHERE
ABE LINCOLN WAS, ALL OF THEM
WERE, AND THAT IS THE WAY IT
WAS.
I'M STANDING HERE AND I SAY
WHILE MATT, FOUR YEARS AS A LONG
TIME.
HERE WE ARE ALMOST COMING UP
WITH TREMENDOUS SUPPORT.
WE HAVE CUT TAXES, WE HAVE CUT
REGULATIONS, GREAT STOCK MARKETS
AND WE HAVE OVER 100 DAYS.
THAT IS IN A FAIRLY SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME WITH THE STOCK MARKET
MUCH MORE THAN 100 DAYS.
HITTING AN ALL-TIME HIGH AND
IT'S ABOUT TO HIT IT AGAIN.
WE ARE DOING GREAT.
AND WE ARE BEATING EVERYBODY.
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
CHINA IS NOT DOING WELL.
CHINA IS HAVING THE WORST YEAR
IN 57 YEARS.
AND WE JUST MADE A DEAL FOR
FARMERS, $40 BILLION TO
$50 BILLION OF AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS BE BOUGHT BY CHINA.
AND WE WILL START BEFORE THEY
START THE AGREEMENT.
WE HAVE DONE THINGS NOBODY ELSE
HAS DONE.
TO GO THROUGH THIS ON A PERFECT
CONVERSATION YOU WILL BE
IMPEACHED, TO MAKE HIM IMPEACHED
AS A VERY UGLY WORD.
IT MEANS A HIGH CRIME
MISDEMEANOR.
THAT LETTER IS A PERFECT
CONVERSATION WITH A MAN,
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR WIN AND
TWO MPH, I DON'T LIKE THAT.
THEY DON'T MENTION THE LETTER
ANYMORE.
AND THEY DON'T MENTION THE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS OR ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE ANYMORE.
>> Sean: THE SECRECY THOUGH.
I WANT YOU TO REACT
NEWT GINGRICH 1998 DID
IMPEACHMENT.
AND THEY WERE DUE PROCESS.
THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEYS, KEVIN
McCARTHY SPELLED IT OUT, AND
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL WROTE A
STRONG LETTER ABOUT HOW THIS
INQUIRY IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
WITHOUT DUE PROCESS AND ITS
UNDOING 2016 AND INFLUENCING
2020.
>> President Trump: SO WHAT
THEY ARE DOING NOW IS SOMETHING
NEVER DONE BEFORE.
AND THEY DON'T WANT THE FACTS TO
COME OUT.
BY THE WAY, FROM EVERYTHING, I
DON'T KNOW MOST OF THESE PEOPLE
AND IF I DO MY MET THEM QUICKLY
OR I KNOW THEM VERY LITTLE, BUT
AMBASSADORS AND SOME OTHERS,
I DON'T EVEN KNOW.
MOST OF THEM I'VE NEVER EVEN
HEARD OF THEIR NAMES COME OKAY?
THEY ARE BRINGING THEM IN AND
TURNING OUT TO BE BETTER FOR US.
BUT WE HAVE NO LAWYERS, NO
REPUBLICANS.
BECAUSE IT IS THE MINORITY.
WE HAVE NO LAWYERS.
WE CAN'T QUESTION, WE CAN'T DO A
THING.
THEY CAN EVEN GO IN THE ROOM.
>> Sean: YOU AND THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN TALKING.
>> President Trump: LOOK AT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE NOT GOOD
POLITICIANS.
I THINK THEY ARE LOUSY POLICY,
THEY HAVE A POLICY OF OPEN
BORDERS AND SANCTUARY CITIES,
CRIME, ALL OF THIS CRIME IT
BRINGS DRUGS, AND I THINK THAT
ALLOWS THE POLITICIANS WITH
HORRIBLE POLICY.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE THE MET
ROMNEY'S OF THE WORLD.
YOU DON'T HAVE PEOPLE THAT WILL
GO AGAINST THE PARTY.
YOU HAD BETTER STICK TOGETHER.
I RESPECT THAT.
THE OTHER THING IS THEY ARE
VICIOUS.
THERE ARE MUCH MORE VICIOUS.
WE WOULD NEVER DO A THING LIKE
THIS.
THEY COULD HAVE IMPEACHED IN
OBAMA FOR THE IRS SCANDAL, THEY
COULD HAVE IMPEACHED HIM FOR THE
CONSOLE OVER THE PLACE AND
PEOPLE GETTING KILLED WITH THE
GUNS FAST AND FURIOUS.
THEY COULD HAVE IMPEACHED HIM
FOR MANY DIFFERENT THINGS.
THEY DIDN'T IMPEACH HIM.
THEN NEVER EVEN THOUGHT OF
IMPEACHING HIM.
HERE, THINK OF THIS.
I'VE GONE THROUGH THE
IMPEACHMENT NOW SINCE THE
BEGINNING.
ON RUSSIA COME ON MUELLER, ON
ALL THE STUFF, OKAY?
AND THEN THEY COME UP WITH THIS
CRAZY CONCEPT OF A PERFECT
CONVERSATION.
I'M SERIOUS.
A VERY GOOD LAWYER SAID "YOU
MUST HAVE KNOWN THIS WOULD BE A
PUBLIC DOCUMENT BECAUSE YOU
SPOKE SO NICELY."
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT.
TO ME, THE WORD IMPEACHMENT IS A
DIRTY, DISGUSTING WORD.
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING FOR A
REASON TO IMPEACH.
THE ONLY REASON THEY ARE
IMPEACHING, THEY LOOK AT THE
POLLS AND RUDY SAID UNDER OATH,
TRUMP WINS EASILY.
>> Sean: 351 ELECTORAL VOTES.
>> President Trump: THEY SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON.
THE LEVEL OF POPULARITY, AND
THEY LOOK AT MINNESOTA.
MINNEAPOLIS WAS INCREDIBLE.
WHEN THEY LOOK AT DALLAS, WHEN
THEY LOOK AT LOUISIANA, WHEN
THEY LOOK AT NORTH CAROLINA AT
THE TWO SEATS IF YOU JUST PICKED
UP.
THEY SEE WHAT IS GOING ON.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE DOING IT.
CONGRESSMAN, A DEMOCRAT SAID WE
HAVE TO IMPEACH HIM.
BECAUSE HE IS GOING TO WIN.
THIS IS WHAT I'M UP AGAINST.
WHO WOULD DO THIS?
WHO WOULD PLAY A DIRTY GAME LIKE
THIS?
>> Sean: WELL, OBVIOUSLY, HE
SAID WE BETTER IMPEACH HIM.
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO BEAT HIM.
THAT WAS A PHRASE.
>> President Trump: NOBODY
BELIEVED THIS SEGMENT BUT BY THE
WAY -- WHEN YOU DO A POLL
COMMAND VERY DEMOCRATS WILL SAY
WE WANT TO WIN.
IMPEACH HIM, GO AHEAD.
IT WOULD BE A TERRIBLE THING FOR
THE COUNTRY, BECAUSE THEN IF YOU
HAVE A DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT AND
SOMEDAY YOU WILL HAVE THIS
COMBINATION, I GUESS, IF YOU
HAVE A DEMOCRAT, HOPEFULLY A
LONG TIME BUT THAT'S OKAY.
YOU HAVE A DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT.
SO WAIT A MINUTE.
LET'S TELL THEM WE ARE RUNNING
FOR 16 YEARS.
BUT LISTEN, SEAN, IF YOU HAVE A
DEMOCRAT AS PRESIDENT AND A
REPUBLICAN HOUSE AND A SPEAKER
THAT IS TOUGH, CRAZY, LIKE
PELOSI, SHE'S CRAZY.
IF YOU HAVE SOMEBODY LIKE THAT,
WHAT HAPPENS IS VERY SIMPLE,
THEY WILL SAY LET'S IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
LET'S CHECK HIS PHONE CALLS, OH,
GEE HEY, PUT IN THE WRONG
LOCATION.
IT IS TO BE FOR HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS.
AND I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS WOULD
NOT BE A LAWSUIT.
HOW CAN YOU TAKE A PRESIDENT AND
THEY DON'T LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
THE PHONE CALL.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
ADAM SCHIFF DOESN'T WANT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER ANYMORE.
YOU KNOW WHY?
HE MIGHT HAVE GIVEN THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER THINGS TO SAY.
>> Sean: HE WOULD HAVE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS ABOUT SCHIFF
AND BIDEN.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT 2020.
SINCE 1969, WHEN YOU RAN, YOU
SAID, WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO LOSE?
WHEN YOU WOULD SPEAK TO
MINORITIES.
NOW YOU HAVE A RECORD LOW
EMPLOYMENT.
>> President Trump: HISTORIC.
>> Sean: HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS, WOMEN IN THE
WORKPLACE, WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE
TO MINORITIES IN 2020?
YOUR BASE LOOK STRONG AND YOU
SEE AT THE RALLIES.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE PEOPLE
WHO MAYBE DIDN'T VOTE FOR YOU
LAST TIME?
>> President Trump:
AFRICAN-AMERICAN, HISPANIC,
ASIAN, AMERICAN HAVE ALL SET
RECORDS, THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT
IN THE HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY,
NOT JUST 50 YEARS.
WE HAVE 51 YEARS FOR THE
COUNTRY, AND WE WILL END UP
TOPPING THAT NUMBER PRETTY SOON.
THAT WILL BE HISTORIC VERY SOON
IF WE KEEP GOING THE WAY WE ARE
DOING AND I THINK WE WILL.
THE HOUSEHOLD INCOME IS SO
INCREDIBLE AND MEDIUM HOUSEHOLD
INCOME.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS COMMAND THE
HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY, THEY
HAVE THE BEST UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS AND THEY HAVE THE BEST
EMPLOYMENT NUMBERS.
TODAY IT WAS ANNOUNCED THAT WE
HAVE THE MOST PEOPLE WORKING IN
THE HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY
ALMOST 160 MILLION.
HOW DO YOU BEAT ME IN A DEBATE
ON THOSE NUMBERS?
OKAY, THE BEST NUMBERS.
POVERTY NUMBERS ARE THE BEST
RIGHT NOW TO ALMOST ALL OF THE
POVERTY NUMBERS MEANING --
>> Sean:
TH Sean:
THESean:
THE Ban:
THE BES:
THE BEST NUMBERS AND THE HISTORY
OF THE COUNTRY.
THERE IS ANOTHER NUMBER THAT
JUST CAME OUT AND IT CAME OUT I
GUESS WITH THE REPORT SAYING I
WOULD WIN EASILY.
THE MOODY'S REPORT WAS VERY
INTERESTING.
MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME UNDER
EIGHT YEARS OF OBAMA WAS UP
$975.
THAT IS EIGHT YEARS.
UNDER EIGHT YEARS OF
PRESIDENT BUSH, PRESIDENT OBAMA,
975.
PRESIDENT BUSH, EIGHT YEARS,
EIGHT YEARS, $400, $975.
ME, TWO AND HALF YEARS, IT IS UP
$7,000, $5,000 PLUS $2,000 FOR
THE TAX CUTS THAT EVERYBODY
CAUGHT.
SO YOU HAVE THE $2,000 YOU ADD
TO THE $5,000 AND YOU HAVE A
THOUSAND, 975,000 BUT THAT IS
OVER EIGHT YEARS EACH ONE.
I'M ONLY HERE TO AND A HALF
YEARS.
AND I BEAT THEM BY MANY TIMES IN
TWO AND HALF YEARS.
THAT PERCENTAGE PROPORTIONATELY.
SO IT IS UP $5,000 PLUS IT IS UP
$7,000, MEDIUM HOUSEHOLD INCOME.
THAT IS A RECORD APPEAR THERE'S
NEVER BEEN ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
THEN I SAY, OH LET'S IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
GIVE ME A BREAK, SEAN.
I DON'T THINK THE PEOPLE WILL
STAND FOR IT.
I REALLY DON'T.
I DON'T THINK THE PEOPLE WILL
STAND FOR IT.
>> Sean: THE LAST WORD, THE
YEAR YOU ARE RUNNING.
>> President Trump: IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS.
>> Sean: WHAT WOULD YOU WANT
MITCH McCONNELL, WHO SAID I
WOULD HAVE TO DO THIS.
SIX WEEKS ON TRIAL FOR WHAT?
>> President Trump: I CAN'T
IMAGINE, I CAN'T IMAGINE THAT
THEY WOULD DO IT.
I CAN'T IMAGINE IT.
IT WOULD BE VERY BAD FOR 40, 45
PEOPLE, THAT ARE DEMOCRATS IN
THE DISTRICT WHEN I RAN I WON
SUBSTANTIALLY IN MANY CASES TO
MY WON BY A LOT.
I DON'T THINK MOST PEOPLE WANT
TO SEE THIS.
IT IS ONE THING IF YOU COMMIT A
REAL CRIME.
THIS WAS NOT EVEN A BIG DEAL.
THIS IS A CONVERSATION.
IT WAS SO PERFECT.
PEOPLE SAY, JUST LIKE A PERFECT
CONVERSATION.
SPEAK TO LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SPEAK TO ALL THESE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE READ IT.
IMPEACHMENT IS HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS.
I THINK IT IS A TRAVESTY FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE DOING SUCH A BAD THING
TO THE COUNTRY.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS ARE VICIOUS, AND THEY
STICK TOGETHER.
FOR INSTANCE, WHEN YOU DO A ON
ADAM SCHIFF, HE MADE UP THE
CONVERSATION.
IT WAS FRAUDULENT.
HE MADE IT SOUND AND HE TOOK
THAT CONVERSATION AND MADE IT
SOUND -- NOW, HE DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT THAT CONVERSATION.
SO HE WENT UP AND MADE A PHONY
CONVERSATION, READ IT TO
CONGRESS, READ IT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND I RELEASED
THAT.
THAT WAS A REAL CONVERSATION.
SO HE THEN SAID "I DON'T KNOW.
IT WAS PARODY.
SO THIS IS A CORRUPT POLITICIAN.
HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
AND NANCY PELOSI SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
THEY SHOULD NOT ALLOW THIS.
WITHOUT IT WILL HELP TO WIN THE
ELECTION.
THEY SAY IT WILL HELP A LOT WITH
RESPECT TO WINNING THE HOUSE
CONTINUE WITH AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS PLAN TO AVOID MORE
ANALYST POLITICIZED WARS.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT SYRIA, AND
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT IRAN.
IRAN DRONE SHOT OUT OF THE AIR,
TINKERS HOSTAGE AND YOU MENTION
ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
LESS GEOPOLITICALLY IMPORTANT.
>> President Trump: WE HAVE
VERY FEW SHIPS BECAUSE SINCE I
CAME IN WE ARE ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
SO THAT COMMENT WAS MADE THE
OTHER DAY BUT THEY DON'T SEE TOO
MANY AMERICAN SHIPS ANYMORE.
>> Sean: WHEN YOU HAVE SYRIA,
YOU HAVE GOTTEN CRITICISM AND IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU AND LINDSAY HAD
AN IMPASSE.
>> President Trump: LOOK, WE
HAVE THE SAME NAME.
YOU WANT TO BRING THE SOLDIERS
BACK HOME.
THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE THERE
FOR 30 DAYS.
THEY ARE THERE FOR TEN YEARS.
AND IN AFGHANISTAN THEY WERE
THERE FOR 20 YEARS.
WE ARE REDUCING THOSE NUMBERS
SUBSTANTIALLY IN AFGHANISTAN.
BUT THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE IN
SYRIA FOR 30 DAYS.
NOW, ONE THING ABOUT SYRIA, WHEN
I TOOK OVER, ISIS WAS ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
YOU KNOW THAT BETTER THAN
ANYBODY.
TWO AND A HALF YEARS AGO.
I WENT IN AND WHEN I STARTED I
GOT RID OF ALL OF THOSE
PRISONERS AND MOST, THEY WERE
CAPTURED UNDER TRUMP.
WE KILLED MANY, MANY ISIS
FIGHTERS.
YOU KNOW, YOU HATE TO TALK ABOUT
IT.
>> Sean: CALIPHATE.
>> President Trump: WE TOOK
100% OF THE CALIPHATE.
100%.
EVERYBODY SAYS IT.
IT'S NOT LIKE OH, GEE, OBAMA DID
IT, I DID IT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, IT IS TIME TO
BRING OURSELVES -- AND IT IS
INTERESTING.
THAT LITTLE FIGHT FOR TWO DAYS,
VICIOUS STUFF.
I DON'T KNOW THAT TURKEY WOULD
HAVE DONE WHAT THEY DID, LIKE
THE CEASE-FIRE.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THE KURDS
WOULD HAVE MOVED OUT.
BUT WE WENT THROUGH TWO DAYS AND
SOME PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WAS A
GREAT ANALOGY.
IT'S LIKE TWO KIDS AND A
PLAYGROUND, THEY FIGHT AND YOU
LET THEM FIGHT MINUTE.
IT WAS MUCH EASIER TO MAKE A
DEAL.
>> Sean: YOU ARE WILLING TO
BECAUSE YOU DID TWO THINGS,
NUMBER ONE, YOUR REMOVED RULES
OF ENGAGEMENT THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD, TWO, YOU
BOMBED THEM AND PUSHED THEM OUT
AND IF NEED BE, MY GUESS IS THAT
I'M ASKING ABOUT THE TRUMP
DOCTRINE IN A SENSE, YOU GO BACK
OVERWHELMING FORCE, NO RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT WHICH TO ME IS LIKE
PUTTING HANDCUFFS ON THE
MILITARY.
>> President Trump: SO WHEN I
GO TO DOVER AIR FORCE BASE AND I
SEE YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN COMING
BACK IN COFFINS, AIKO TO THE
WALTER REED HOSPITAL, AND
INCREDIBLE MILITARY DOCTORS.
WHAT THEY CAN DO FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE.
AND I SEE PEOPLE, YOUNG,
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE, SUCH
INCREDIBLE -- I SERVED THERE
LAST FRIDAY AND I GOT PURPLE
HEARTS, SO BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE THAT
OFTEN TIMES THEY ARE MISSING
LEGS AND ARMS, THEY ARE MISSING
BOTH.
AND I SEE THE PARENTS, AND I SEE
THE HEARTBREAK.
THE DEVASTATION AND THE
HEARTBREAK.
I SIGNED LETTERS RIGHT HERE IN
THIS OFFICE, THE OVAL OFFICE MY
SIGNED LETTERS FOR PARENTS.
>> Sean: NO TWO LETTERS OF THE
SAME.
>> President Trump: NO TWO
LETTERS ARE EVER THE SAME.
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THEM
DIFFERENT.
THEY COMPARE THEM.
YOU KNOW IT IS INTERESTING EVEN
THOUGH THEY MAY NOT BE THE SAME
PART OF THE COUNTRY, WHEN THEY
DIE, THE PARENTS GET TOGETHER TO
TALK ABOUT THEIR SONS OR
DAUGHTERS KILLED.
AMAZING, I DON'T WANT TO READ A
ONE LETTER, MAKE EVERY LETTER
DIFFERENT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ME.
>> Sean: WE START WARS.
WE POLITICIZED WARS.
THEN WE GET NERVOUS POLITICALLY.
AND THEN IT SEEMS, WE PUT
HANDCUFFS ON THE MILITARY.
VIETNAM, IRAQ, AFGHANISTAN,
LOOK, EVERYTHING IS POLITICIZED.
IS THE NEXT STEP, MAYBE THE
TRUMP DOCTRINE EVEN THAT THE
NEXT GENERATION OF WEAPONRY,
OFFENSIVE AND DEFENSIVE WEAPONS
WILL WE FIGHT THEM FROM TAMPA?
HE SPENT A LOT OF MONEY.
>> President Trump: WE ARE
MAKING MOST SOPHISTICATED
WEAPONS EVER MADE.
WHERE MAKING THE GREATEST
MISSILES, THE GREATEST ROCKETS,
AND OUR NUCLEAR IS NOW UP TO
SNUFF AT A LEVEL IT'S NEVER
BEEN.
WE ARE ACTUALLY NUCLEAR AND
BUILDING NUCLEAR, NOT THAT I
WANT TO, BUT AS YOU KNOW, RUSH
IS NOT PLAYING FAIR WITH US WITH
THE TREATY.
WE THEREFORE, TERMINATED IT.
I BELIEVE WE GET TOGETHER WITH
RUSSIA, CHINA, WE WILL WORK OUT
A NUCLEAR PACK SO WE DON'T ALL
CONTINUE WITH THIS CRAZINESS.
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE THE MOST
POWERFUL NUCLEAR FORCE IN THE
WORLD.
RUSSIA IS SECOND AND CHINA IS
THIRD.
IT IS VERY COSTLY AND VERY
DANGEROUS.
IT IS VERY, VERY DANGEROUS.
AND WE ARE DISCUSSING WITH
RUSSIA AND WE ARE DISCUSSING
WITH CHINA DURING THE RECENT
TRADE DEAL WITH CHINA, I SAID,
WE SHOULD ALL GET TOGETHER AND
WORK OUT SOMETHING, HAVE A CAP,
HAVE A CAP.
WE DON'T NEED 10,000 WEAPONS.
TO HAVE CAP.
AND I WILL SAY, CHINA AND RUSSIA
IN TALKING ABOUT IT ARE
EXTREMELY EXCITED ABOUT IT.
>> Sean: WE HAVE TO HAVE
TRUST.
>> President Trump: 100% WE
NEED ALL OF THAT.
I'M THE ONE THAT TERMINATED THE
AGREEMENT.
THEY DIDN'T TERMINATE IT BECAUSE
WE FOUND THEY WERE DOING THINGS
THEY WERE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING IN THE AGREEMENT.
SO WE HAD AN AGREEMENT, YOU
KNOW, A NUCLEAR AGREEMENT, AND
WE ALSO HAD ALL SORTS OF LIMITS
AND WE WERE THE ONLY ONE PAYING
ATTENTION TO IT.
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
BUT NOW THEY KNOW WE ARE A
DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
AND I THINK RUSSIA WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A DEAL, AND I THINK CHINA
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A DEAL PIER
THAT WILL BE A TERRIFIC THING.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE A PART OF
THAT.
>> Sean: I WAS SURPRISED YOU
DIDN'T HIT IRAN.
>> President Trump: WE HAVE A
LOT OF GOOD DEALS.
THEY TOOK DOWN THEIR DRONES AND
THERE WAS NOBODY IN IT.
THEY TOOK DOWN A SECOND ROUND
AND THERE WAS NOBODY IN IT.
HITTING SAUDI ARABIA, WE SENT
TROOPS OVER TO SAUDI ARABIA.
SAUDI ARABIA IS PAYING FOR IT.
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
WE SAID YOU HAVE TO PAY AND THEY
ARE PAYING AND THEY HAVE NOTHING
BUT MONEY, NOTHING BUT CASH AND
THEY ARE PAYING.
WE SENT SOME TROOPS OVER THERE.
WE WILL GIVE THEM GOOD
PROTECTION.
WE HAVE A LOT OF GOOD CAPITAL.
EVERYBODY THOUGHT WHEN I GOT
ELECTED, HILLARY CLINTON USED TO
SAY, OH, YOU WILL HAVE WORLD WAR
III.
PHIL, AND VERY TEMPERED,
ACTUALLY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, I HAVE BUILT UP
A LOT OF CAPITAL.
>> Sean: BY NOT GETTING.
>> President Trump: BY NOT
EATING.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> Sean: THE CALIPHATE.
>> President Trump: I WIPED
OUT THE CALIPHATE AND YOU SAW
WHEN I HIT 58 ROCKETS, MISSILES
RIGHT INTO THE TOMAHAWK'S, RIGHT
INTO THE MIDDLE OF SYRIA.
AND KNOCKED OUT A WHOLE BASE.
WHICH IS SOMETHING, BY THE WAY
PRESIDENT OBAMA DREW THE RED
LINE IN THE SAND AND DID NOT
VIOLATE THE RED LINE.
WHEN HE DIDN'T DO IT, THAT'S
WHEN EVERYBODY ELSE CAME AND
INCLUDING RUSSIA.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION --
>> President Trump: THAT WAS A
BIG MOMENT.
HE SAID RED LINE IN THE SAND AND
THEN WHAT THEY DID WAS THEY HAD
CHEMICALS AND THEY DESTROYED 500
BABIES AND CHILDREN.
HE DIDN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
THAT WAS A VERY BAD MOMENT FOR
>> Sean: WELCOME BACK TO
"HANNITY" FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
HERE IS THE FINAL QUESTION I
ASKED PRESIDENT TRUMP TODAY AT
HIS ANSWER.
I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR A LONG TIME.
YOU'VE ALREADY GIVEN THE ANSWER
EARLIER TODAY.
WE MIGHT MOVE TO CAMP DAVID I
GUESS.
I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR A LONG TIME.
YOU THRIVE ON A BATTLE.
YOU THRIVE ON FIGHTING.
YOU SAID TO ME PRIVATELY AND
PUBLICLY, YOU WANT YOUR PROMISE
IS FULFILLED.
I GUESS THAT IS WHAT REELECTION
CAN BE ABOUT.
ALL OF THIS IMPEACH, IMPEACH.
DO YOU CARE?
WOULD YOU CARE AT ALL WHAT THEY
DO AS LONG AS YOU WIN BACK IN
NOVEMBER?
DOESN'T MATTER TO YOU?
>> President Trump: WE'VE DONE
A GREAT JOB, THE ECONOMY IS THE
BEST IT'S EVER BEEN.
YOU LOOK AGAIN, CHINA HAS GONE
WAY DOWN.
IF HILLARY CLINTON HAD GOTTEN
ELECTED RIGHT NOW CHINA WOULD
HAVE THE NUMBER ONE ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD AND RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
NOT EVEN CLOSE.
THEY'RE WAY BEHIND.
WE PICKED UP TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN WORTH AND VALUE AND
CHINA HAS GONE WAY, WAY DOWN BY
TRILLIONS AND TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
WHEN THE HEAD OF CHINA SPOKE TO
ME RECENTLY AND EVEN THE
VICE-PREMIER JUST LEFT.
JUST LEFT THIS OFFICE RIGHT HERE
LAST WEEK.
HE SAID, CONGRATULATIONS
MR. PRESIDENT ON THE INCREDIBLE
JOB.
HE SAID WE WOULD HAVE NEVER HAVE
EXPECTED THIS TO HAPPEN.
DON'T FORGET, CHINA IS PAYING US
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS NO
IN TARIFFS.
IT HASN'T COST US ANYTHING
BECAUSE THEY'VE DEVALUED THEIR
CURRENCY AND THEY POURED MONEY.
IT HASN'T COST US ANYTHING.
THEY BEATEN IT.
THEY BEATEN IT TOTALLY.
HE SAID CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
JOB YOU'VE DONE WITH THE ECONOMY
JOB YOU'VE DONE WITH THE ECONOM
ECONOMY.
HAD HILLARY CLINTON.END, WE
WOULD BE THE NUMBER TWO ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD.
WE ARE SO FAR IN FRONT OF CHINA
THAT WE HAVE SMART PEOPLE
SITTING RIGHT IN THAT CHAIR,
RIGHT NEXT TO US, IT WILL NEVER
HAPPEN.
>> Sean: I THINK YOU MUST
NEGOTIATE EVERYTHING RATE OF 90
FOR A LONG TIME.